[Music]
bring up when is the wedding we haven't
set a date date yet but we're gonna do
it this year so um well I think towards
the end of the year making the middle
beer maybe maybe a little low you don't
know hey it's January 2nd is happening
we just haven't been like this is the
exact day yet okay yeah we decide we
wait till January to start really
planning I'm saying that we are planning
in January how does our plenary plan
month yeah plan you Airy perfect God
would you do a TV wedding or what's
going on with that
that's all those things we we just have
to like work through is it on the table
it's on the table I kind of told Evan I
was like whatever you want to do you
just did you find out what you want to
do and then all plan it is the reverse
it felt normal
I know but I don't really I've never
been that growth like this is my dress
these are my flowers I don't care like I
would marry him at a courthouse to me
fine well we've got somebody special in
the comments my lord
when I had Vinnie on here well let me
take a little comment for Vinnie and now
Vinnie is up paying it forward he's got
a question for you t he wants to know
who is going to DJ your wedding we're
having a live band is a great question
he's not a particular set of skills
that's any guy let's drive roll of
course you are Vinnie I think you just
earned yourself a paying gig wedding
game Kristen wants to know will anyone
else from the show be in your wedding
anybody who would be a bridesmaid or
groomsman who you guys thinking um
definitely Jayde and Julia will be my
bridesmaids for sure yeah I know that's
the challenge I want to I definitely
like well is gonna be in there for sure
like Nick is gonna be a part whether
it's officiating you know we talked
about him officiating it so crazy Chris
here some I have to fight them then
there's a few others guys like Vinny you
know like you want to have them have
everybody yeah it just depends on what
the wedding it is crazy how this like
bachelor family like we really do love
each other